well as the white house limits the
media's border access to just
one pool camera republican senators are
making their own border visit tomorrow
wisconsin gop center ron johnson will be
on that trip and he joins us now
with more senator thank you for being
here with us this morning both ted cruz
and yourself have suggested
you will invite the national media to
come down with you to see the conditions
along the texas border do you expect to
be able to accomplish that goal will you
find
success in bringing the press along good
morning you know my guess is this
administration will block it because
they don't want
the public to see what we'll be able to
see the disaster that is growing at the
border and you know
guys this is so sad this didn't have to
happen this was not only predictable it
was predicted
you know during my chairmanship as as
chairman of homeland
uh security committee we held 30
hearings
and we've we've heard all this before
we've seen how these surges are used by
the
the sex traffickers and the human
traffickers the drug traffickers
we know we know the inhumanity that this
is going to be sparking
and apparently the administration is
just deaf dumb and blind to it
senator you know seasoned journalists
have been on our show and and other
fox shows and have said that the access
uh
for the media is better in mexico than
here in the united states which is
embarrassing i just want to see if you
could explain to our viewers
why a u.s senator can't demand to see
what's going on in facilities that are
being paid for
by the taxpayers and the conditions of
these children in a
in a situation that we know as you said
was caused by this administration
because customs border protection is the
administration
an executive office agency and they
control it we don't
now we're obviously going to go down
there i think a group of 19 of us are
going to go down there to highlight this
and you know coming on shows like this
can also make the public aware of this
but uh you know let's face it president
trump was able to
largely fix the problem with the
families and unaccompanied children
exploiting our
asylum laws and and we pretty well
brought that to an end
by the way with with virtually no help
from democrats i
i did get some help from democrat
senator kirsten cinema
she worked with me on operation safe
return which we presented to dhs and
kind of morphed into the return to
mexico policy
but now now that i've heard that vice
president harris is going to be put in
charge of this
she is the worst choice she was on my
committee
she did nothing to help stop the flow
she basically came to hearings and asked
really
uh obnoxious questions to ice and cbp
basically accusing them of inhumanity
that's about all she did she had she had
no interest whatsoever in working with
the administration to
secure the border and stop the flow well
senator when she was running
for president in 2019 she said if i'm
elected president united states
i'm going to release the kids from the
cages they've got
one of the places the so-called kids
with cages place is a place you're going
to visit tomorrow in donna texas
and so it'll be interesting to see and
it apparently is a super spreader event
uh because when when you look at the
numbers that the government has
actually released and they're always
spinning the numbers they say that close
to 3 000 kids have had
covid in federal custody but they don't
test everybody
so that is probably just the tip of the
iceberg no
what we're seeing is just the tip of the
iceberg and remember in 2014 when
president obama
labeled that crisis at humanitarian
crisis uh his secretary dhs jay johnson
said a thousand people being apprehended
today
was a really bad day i've just heard
reports that we've had a day where
6 000 people were apprehended remember
this happens day after day after day
it's overwhelming our personnel it's
overwhelming our facility and what this
administration is going to do
is they're going to go into full release
it's it's you know it's back to catch
and release it's
apprehend process and disperse
throughout america tune to four
five six thousand people per day that's
a caravan a day
you're right when you when senators and
and members of congress go down to the
border it at least brings attention to a
situation that clearly the
administration
doesn't want us to know about so thank
you for doing that trip this week
well thank you for having me on and
highlighting this this this is
this is a disaster it's it's not just a
challenge it is a disaster and we're
just seeing the tip of the iceberg it's
going to get worse